let's go to the phones which are
functioning a little bit weirdly today
let's try to start with someone I didn't
get to last time Ronald Reagan calling
it
Ronald what's going on hey David has
begun good how are you good
you may remember I know you don't like
to get an online possessive drama but I
was a few months ago I brought up that
you had somewhat copied the Sam cedar
majority report set right and the the
accusation was that you were trying to
coast off you know Sam's whatever his
intellectual property right that was the
the idea but I just want to let you know
I had a sort of you know the usual
suspects are you familiar with this film
yes I am yeah and you know how at the
end the detective sort of looks around
his office and he realizes he he's had
everything all wrong this whole time and
I had a moment like that the other day
when I was listening to Sam's toe and a
caller called in and said that she was
new to his show and he asked how how did
you come to find out about the show and
she said that she first started by
listening to you
beautiful and and that you know in the
YouTube recommendations or whatever she
actually clicked over to Sam's show so
it could be it sounds like to me from
the evidence that actually Sam was
trying to get you to adopt his
intellectual property to create
confusion amongst your audience so that
your audience would leak over into his
struggling podcast I think I think
that's spot-on in fact I think that
probably 80 or 90% of Sam's audience is
people thinking that I've allowed
someone else to use my studio I think
you're making an incredibly astute
assessment here
yeah and it's uh you know I you're a
smart guy but it's sad that you got
tricked into doing that by saying them
but but that's okay you know I think
that you're doing all right I did want
to ask you because all jokes aside I
really like your clips on YouTube and I
find myself in you know just sort of
having them on I don't know anything
about like your scheduling or like when
you do your show how often it is
and so I I wish you would give somebody
like me who's kind of new to to your
show rundown of exactly what you have to
offer right so we do we do five episodes
a week Monday to Friday we film it in
the early afternoon and then we start
clipping it up doing a podcast version
and all of the stuff starts going out
out around 3:30 or 4:00 p.m. Eastern
time each weekday and then so you know
we'll publish clips to YouTube from that
day's show that day will hold a couple
for the weekend so that we have stuff
publishing each day of the week and then
our radio and TV affiliates and
satellite TV run the show anywhere from
like 5:00 p.m. to 11:00 p.m. Eastern
Time that day
from what we filmed earlier in the
afternoon I said and what is your
preferred way of you know people
supporting the show is there you know
patreon or they need to go to your
website we have a patreon but as people
may know patreon takes five to nine
percent depending on certain factors
that are boring to get into so the way
the majority of the money to get to us
is the website memberships cuz we just
pay two point nine percent for swiping
credit cards and then otherwise we get
the rest so that's where we keep the
most money when people go to our website
all right I think all right Ronald
Reagan great to hear from you always
good we will be updating your rating in
the caller system because you were a
clear concise and director during
today's phone call I appreciate that